welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact Dermatologists
tell us that bathing too often may not
be good for your skin but obviously not
bathing often enough can cause serious
social problems
take for example Alma Hodge who
apparently has earned the distinction of
being the dirtiest man in the world
believing that washing would make him
sick Hodge who lives outside a village
in the fars province of Iran has not had
a shower or a bath in the last 60 years
mr. Hodge 80 now says that he chose this
way of life after going through some
emotional setbacks in his youth and
since then not surprisingly he's become
a little bit isolated his clothing
appears to be a collection of dirty rags
and when he needs a haircut
he simply singes his hair with a burning
stick at night he either sleeps in a
hole in the ground which looks very much
like a grave or in an open brick Shack
that some concerned neighbors build for
him he drinks his water from a rusty oil
can in his favorite meal is rotten
porcupine to relax he sits down and he
smokes a pipe packed with dung once a
group of young men tried to capture him
and give him a shower but luckily he
says he managed to escape when asked if
there's anything he wanted he said I'd
like to find a wife evidently he's not
figured out why he's having a problem
with that you know the Bible tells us
about a man who took seven baths in one
day stay with his friends we're going to
learn more as amazing facts brings you
this edition of Bible answers live
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible question
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
sets 1-800 four six three seventy to
ninety seven now let's join our host
pastor Doug Batchelor welcome listening
friends this is Bible answers live and
it is a live international interactive
Bible study program that's interactive
because we're encouraging you to call in
with your Bible questions lines are open
now a lot of lines open good chance
you'll get your Bible question on
tonight's program let me give you the
number again it's 800 god says is the
acronym because we use the book of God
for our answers 804 6 372 97 one more
time 804 6 3 7 2 97 i am doug batchelor
and tonight pastor ross is overseas in
serbia but we've got our good friend
pastor marshall mckenzie helping out yes
and maybe you'll open the program where
to prayer for us that would be great
well father in heaven we thank you so
much for this opportunity we have to ask
our Bible questions this evening and we
just pray that you will guide our
thoughts may you be glorified at all
that is said in Jesus name we pray amen
amen
you know pastor Doug I was listening to
that story that you were sharing in it
it just reminded me of even more so the
story of naman that you had mentioned
and how he needed to bathe well you know
where we were going being a pastor
there's this story about and you find
his friends in 2nd Kings chapter 5 the
second book of Kings chapter 5 talks
about a famous general by the name of
Nalin who has leprosy and which is a
symbol for sin in the Bible and he's
dying from it it's a deadly disease and
he has a servant girl in his house that
says off you just go to the prophet in
Israel that's the elation of the prophet
he could heal you so naman brings an
entourage with money and chariots and he
comes into Elisha says he sends a
servant out the servant tells name and
wash in the Jordan River seven times
well that really makes name--and man
these storms away because basically
saying you need seven baths and the
jordan river is not even a clean river
so when you say you take seven baths in
a muddy river it implies you're even
dirtier than the water so he goes away
his pride is wounded but he has to go by
the jordan river to get back to syria
and his servants persuade him why don't
you do what the Prophet said what did he
get to lose you're going home to die so
he goes and he dips himself seven times
in the river and his leprosy is a
cleanse and he's so thankful he goes all
the way back to Samaria to thank Elisha
and you know it made me think about when
I read this story about a man who is
that dirty now you traveled in India and
in India in other parts of the world but
sometimes there people who for
religiously reasons don't take baths I
mean we always our hearts break for
people who do it for poverty but and I
once lived on the streets and I won't go
into it but I know I've been there and
anyway I remember reading about someone
that was in a prison of war camp and
they were among the ones who were
liberated and they had not been able to
take a bath in months and they said how
long it took them to soak in the tub to
get clean yeah so but you know the Bible
talks about that bath of naman in the
Jordan River is a symbol of where John
the Baptist baptized in the Jordan and
people were washed symbolically from
their sins and I don't know if you've
ever thought about what's meant by the
internal cleansing that God tells us of
in his word and we can be clean because
anyone can hopefully get a bath or a
shower and there's truck stops where you
can get a shower but where you get the
internal cleaning and we have a free
offer that will talk about how can we be
clean inside and out the Bible says
blessed are the pure in heart they will
see God we have a free study guide we'll
send anyone who asks and it will talk
you about this that purity and we'll
also talk to you about baptism and it's
called power impurity power impurity
the number if you'd like a free copy 800
this is a different number from the
studio so got it down 800 eight three
five six seven four seven and maybe we
need prayer we have chaplains available
to pray with you eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven for our
resource and chaplain number if you want
to call in with a question eight hundred
four six three seven two nine seven and
of course we got gobs and rules of
material at the amazing facts website
that's very simply amazing facts dot org
alright pastor Marshall who is our first
call tonight our first caller is Warren
from Huntsville Alabama Warren you're on
Bible answers live with Pastor Doug all
right have some dope have some more sure
how y'all doing tonight good how you
doing good all right my portion includes
the ESPYs 1019 pleasee asti 1019 I'm
going there now right you want me to
read that for everybody or you read
because our listeners a lot of our folks
are driving down the road and they can't
really get a Bible says a feast is made
for laughter and wine makes merry but
money answers everything now that large
part but money and everything explained
it well Solomon of course was very
wealthy
he had observed that you could probably
pay a person to tell jokes and make up
his laugh and you could buy wine and he
saw money he said you know a lot of
people they'll come to the king and
they'll be complaining if someone didn't
treat him right in the king will say
well what kind of settlement would make
you feel better
well you'd put it that way you know you
give me ten pieces of gold and I'm okay
and so Solomon just observed that
there's so much of the problems that
people have with each other can be
resolved there they're looking for some
kind of financial settlement people
looking for happiness they think power
and influence can come from money and so
the book of Ecclesiastes Solomon is
making he says everything is vanity and
he's talking about the below aspirations
of man
people like to laugh and they like to
have a drink and and feel merry but he
said what really they're after in the
long run is money and the power to buy
those things I guess he even sounds a
little cynical there does that make
sense
uh yeah it's like well he doesn't you
know it's similar to what Paul said when
Paul said money can be the root of all
evil and that so that's that's what I
think Solomon is referring to he said
money answers everything okay hey
appreciate your question thank you very
much Warren and we'll look forward to
hearing from you again god bless our
next question is from Chris in Florida
Chris in Florida here on Bible answers
live with Pastor Doug hello hi Chris
you're on the air yes thank you very
much but how are you doing thank you
very much um my question is simply about
when Jesus was born of the Virgin Mary
and was he was he a human only or God
and human at the same time all right
you're asking a big question about what
the Bible defines as a mystery there are
a couple of mysteries in the Bible the
Bible talks about the mystery of
iniquity and you'll find also that in
revelation 17 that harlots got a
paragraph on her forehead says Mystery
Babylon and then you get the mystery of
godliness and Paul said that it is a
mystery how God becomes a man and so how
Jesus could be a hundred percent man and
what I mean by that is when Jesus was a
baby he needed to be fed like a baby he
needed his diaper change like a baby he
needed to learn to walk like a baby so
Jesus was a hundred percent human in
those respects but probably around the
time he was 12 years old and he went to
the temple he became aware through the
Spirit of God of His divine mission
that's why he told his parents I must be
about my father's business and so there
was an Enlightenment that happened
some point in his life and there was
something divine about him so Jesus was
God in man the Bible says God was in
Christ reconciling the world to himself
so you and I it's difficult for us to
comprehend the Incarnation and karne
means the flesh how Jesus entered human
flesh and became a human so how can a
person be a hundred percent human and a
hundred percent God that ends up with
200 percent is doesn't add up for us but
the Bible teaches that somehow God did
that in Jesus yes because it's the
reason I'm asking that question is that
someone on the radio said well I'm being
I was raised Catholic and there was a
prayer that Catholics ISIL Mary Mary
Mother of God
Mary Mother of God pray for us so he
said that there is nowhere in the Bible
that says that the Jesus when she was
born of those in Mary was actually God
but only a human yeah you don't find the
phrase pastor Marshall - but I don't
think you find the phrase mother of God
in the Bible and she's always called
Jesus mother and Mary when she gave
birth to Jesus it was a natural birth as
far as we know it kind of supernatural
and that the angels came and later the
surya angels came shepherds came and
later the Weizmann came but you know
Jesus in those respects he was he acted
like a normal baby but as he grew he
understood his divine mission and the
God he was filled with the Spirit of God
he was anointed with the Spirit of God
that's what Christ means so but you know
I think it can give people the wrong
impression when we refer to Mary as a
mother of God and almost there's an
effort and it with a Catholic background
you know this and I used to go to
Catholic school that there's sort of an
effort to deify Mary because they pray
to Mary and they make Mary almost like a
many a mini God right right so there's a
big emphasis on the mother of God part I
was just thinking pastor Doug we have
two free offers actually that probably
deal with this yeah
one of those is down from his glory it's
down from his glory the second one is
Christ's human nature form and you can
get those at our resource line
1-800-816-6088 get satellite to years
ago in San Antonio right I know when I
was in your state two weeks ago well my
question is its job
we know Eve was deceived and Adam chose
evil with God if Adam would have chosen
God over heed what would you have done -
Eve you know other people have asked
that question before and it's one of
those hypothetical questions where all I
can't tell you biblically this is what
he would have done I know that God is
just and I doubt he would have made Adam
experience all of the fall out of sin
just for what either done but then you
say well what would have happened to Eve
and you know we've got two or three
options the Lord might have activated a
plan of salvation for Eve I don't know
it's a hypothetical question
and so all I can do is speculate which
is worth about a nickel here so it was
this boat several people have asked that
that's a tough question a lot of people
said they were destroyed her because she
didn't care we get the population and
her loins or wasn't able to and and I'm
just curious and you right he is it just
God so that's a question they don't have
to be after to heaven I guess
yeah the you know I'm I'm reluctant to
say he would have just snuffed her out
because he loved Eve as much as you
loved Adam and because we were both
created equal or they were yeah and then
God of course he was patient with
Lucifer when the angels rebelled he
didn't instantly kick them out of heaven
he bore with them and encouraged them to
repent and so I think he would have done
something to try to redeem Eve
I don't know again I'm speculating so
it's hard to say he would have to filled
it left for her one eat well if she's
going to be saved they have a penalty
for sin so yeah again all that like I
said it's we're speculating but it would
be pretty rough to say well since man
sinned Jesus has to die but if it's just
a woman they're expendable we'll just
make another one
yeah that's that's one kind of I kind of
pounded on that one
well what quick one we know we
experienced death as a human race do any
of the demons experience death prior to
them prior to Jesus Christ comes back I
don't think so because the Bible says
that they are spirits and it talks about
them being reserved in everlasting
chains so I don't think that the devil
gets tired and sleeps I don't think they
die and like a physical death they will
be cast in the lake of fire and
exterminated at the end of time but yeah
doesn't in Jude and Peter they get
second Peter talked about them being
kept in Chains of darkness but they're
conscious they're bound to this world
right now right they're reserved down
time and we have a lesson that you might
enjoy on that Covino that's talks about
thousand years of peace we'll be happy
to send you a free copy our gif in
number if you want to call that is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and ask for a thousand years of
peace okay okay I got next our next
question is from Rob in North Carolina
Rob you're on Bible answers live with
pastor Doug hey thanks a lot pastors I
have a general observation in Genesis
after Adam and Eve sinned an angel was
immediately placed at the Tree of Life
so
they couldn't get to it and become
immortal centers it seems like they have
to eat one time in their immortal
centers but yet when you make it to
heaven or the earth may move you have to
continually eat from the tree to be
immortal and then the second part of
that is will Christ himself have to eat
from that tree and the earth may know
all right got some good questions there
first thing I might respectfully
disagree with you I think even in the
Garden of Eden that Adam and Eve needed
to continue to eat from the tree
I believe that Adam he probably ate from
the tree of life before they ate from
the forbidden tree they may have lived
in the garden for months or years I
don't think they were there very long
because even not had any children yet
and you know they were told to be
fruitful right away so they probably but
I think they may have eaten from the
tree which could be why Adam and Eve
lived hundreds of years and their
posterity and then the lifespan dropped
after that just the vital force ran out
scientists don't know why are cells
degrade but there's something in the DNA
of ourselves it is missing something
some essences prevents them free from
regenerating and we die now we could
continue lead from that tree I think
that we'd have that vitality they don't
necessarily need to eat from it every
day but you know I I think that both on
earth and in heaven they would have the
privilege of continuing to eat from that
tree your next question was what Jesus
need to eat from that tree and I don't
think so because even though Jesus took
on human form if he's the one that makes
whatever is in the tree of life he could
just make it in his own veins if he
wants to so you know he's God he's got
his a glorified eternal body now and and
all things are possible with God I can't
even speculate him starting to atrophy
because he didn't get to the Korean time
so anyway I appreciate that Rob I'm just
hoping I'm there and I can taste the
fruit amen yeah thank you very much our
next caller is Phil in Old Bethpage New
York Phil you're on the air with Bible
answers live and pastor Doug well thank
you very much thank you very much would
taken my call it's rather similar to the
previous
is cool question is when Adam and Eve
were living in the Garden of Eden before
they ate the forbidden food was eaten
the entire earth was was it simply
another place on earth like Boston well
I hope it will look better than Boston
nothing Prada nobody I actually lived in
Boston years ago you know I believe it
was a specific spot because it describes
it as between a set of rivers and so it
sort of designates a region it says the
Lord planted after God makes the earth
it in plants a garden and he gives a
place where the garden was planted E&C
made a garden on the earth you know many
people have supposedly gone on these
epic quests looking for the Garden of
Eden in the Tree of Life and the
Fountain of Youth and but all of that
was erased during the time of Noah's
Flood it's very likely that the Garden
of Eden this beautiful garden planted by
God you know may have been a hundred
times bigger than Central Park in New
York City was brought up to heaven
somehow before the flood destroyed the
world because the tree of life in the
garden is in the New Jerusalem when it
descends from heaven at the end of the
one thousand years that's revelation 21
so you're going hiking all over the
world you'll find some beautiful places
but you won't find the Garden of Eden
you'll find places that are called the
guard to be inked that are beautiful but
it's nothing like what God had planted
and we will see it someday we do have a
lesson that talks about the City of God
in the Garden of Eden in that city and
it's called a city in space that's right
and we'll be happy to send that to you
if you'd like a free copy fill that
number yeah it's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven asked
for the study guide the city in space
perfect our next question is Shia shouts
from the Virgin Islands aya you're on
the air Bible answers live and pastor
Doug hi thank you for taking my call
thank you for calling
your pretend she was on I was I call it
a few like last year now is that and I
asked a question
um about Adam and Eve about that she of
lotions just oh good we just had a
question on that now how old are you
Shia and twelve good she called when
you're 11 now you call when you're 12
and your question so I was wondering if
it's okay to stay around unsaved family
members well that's a good question if
you're a believer and you've got some
family members that aren't believers can
you stay around them well you always
want to be able to be a positive
influence on your unsaved family because
how else are you going to lead them to
Christ and be and witness to them if
you're never will but sometimes you get
family members that you know their
language is very bad and and they got
some bad habits that are pretty
unhealthy and being around them can
sometimes be a dangerous experience even
though they're family and you love them
there the experience is so intense so
difficult that you can't take very much
of it so you just need wisdom and your
parents can give you guidance on that
but you know you don't want to cut
yourself off from your family because
they don't believe like you but at the
same time you gotta you know some family
members can drag you down spiritually
and you can only do it in little doses
one that makes sense
yes I know we had that too and when we
were growing up I'm the only Christian
in my side of the family and so when we
would take our kids we go visit
relatives it was a challenge sometimes
because that the language the drinking
and he's right yeah you had to just have
a try and control the environment for a
little while and love while you can and
then dad to escape seized of it anyway
yeah thanks for calling Shiloh or Shia
yeah our next call pastor Doug is Dennis
from cross Lake Minnesota Dennis here on
the air Bible answer is live and pastor
Doug
Dennis bow Thank You Chuck thank you
Pastor Doug I have a question about
Romans 424 about imputed righteousness
do we receive that and the water baptism
or baptism of the Holy Spirit and once
we have like Jesus Christ in us do is we
repeated I guess and tended to we always
have it or couldn't we reject it or
particularly if you were taken away from
us yeah and your thoughts on this sure
let me read the verse for people that
are maybe driving down the road in
Romans 424 I can read verse 23 to Paul
says now it was not written for the his
sake alone that it was imputed to him
but also for us that it might be imputed
to us who believed in him raised Jesus
from the dead and so he's talking about
Abraham and Sarah and abraham believed
God and God imputed that means he gave
him credit it's like justification for
his faith because he believed God gave
him credit for righteousness before the
boy was even born
based on his faith he was given credit
and so by our faith in Jesus and his
sacrifice he impute sir he gives us
credit for his righteousness now before
we ever do our first good work
Christians who are saved will do good
works not to be saved but because they
are saved but before we do any good
works we receive righteousness as a gift
that is imputed to us by faith and so
can we lose that well if we stop
believing yeah in the Bible talks about
how we need to abide in our faith and
you know sometimes our faith will be
tested it doesn't mean we've immediately
lost our righteousness but does that
make sense Dennis yeah so cuz I kind of
always believed that once you're refuted
with the Holy Spirit that you are
righteous in the eyes of God the Father
and if you don't have that right justice
you know you're not I just look out the
Father I guess yeah and you're right
that when we have been we've accepted
Christ by faith
the gift of the Holy Spirit and we can
it doesn't mean that we can never lose
faith or never grieve away the spirit
because you do find examples of people
in the Bible you know it says in
Ephesians 2 do not grieve the Holy
Spirit and King David prays in Psalm 51
take not thy Holy Spirit from me restore
unto me the joy of thy spirit because he
had kind of grieved the spirit when he
sinned with Bathsheba and killed Uriah
and all of that business so it's
something that we need to nurture even
though we receive it as a gift Paul said
I die daily and Jesus had give us this
day our daily bread walking with Christ
it's like running a farm someone said
you starting it every day with a new
beginning you have assurance you got
faith but you need to continue to strive
to walk with God hey Dennis appreciate
your question and I have a book I'll
send you a free copy and it's called
assurance salvation made simple we'll
send you a free copy just call 883 five
six seven four seven ask for Pastor
Doug's book on assurance we'll be glad
to send that to you you hear the
tinkling of the music behind his friends
the program is not over we're going to
take a break for some station
identification probably get a drink of
water and we've got Bible answer lines
opened give us a call with your Bible
questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment I really wanted to
start a new devotional habit but life
got in the way next thing I know we're a
month into the new year and I'm like
what's the point of starting then I saw
365 amazing answers to big Bible
questions each day is a single study you
can start anywhere on any day and not
miss a thing their crisp clear vivid
lightning get yours today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767
to come you know every week we hear the
most incredible stories from all over
the globe a lives that are being changed
and hearts that are being transformed by
the power of the word and none of it
could happen without your teamwork with
this ministry
god bless you
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 seventy two
nine seven dial an 800 first and that
will bring your call into the studio and
we've got several lines open good chance
to get on tonight my name is Doug
Batchelor and mine is Marshall Mackenzie
and we're going to take this call here
this is cliff pastor Doug cliff is in
Florida cliff here on Bible answers live
hi hey pastor my question is concerned
I'm little confused on these thousands
of when Satan is down for a thousand
years I believe he keeps that found on
the bottomless pit is Earth basically
found on earth for their selves and uses
that for it yes the word bottomless pit
that you find there in Revelation has
confused people the Greek word there as
abussos it's where we get the word
abyss that we all recognize same word
and the word abyss it just means in the
void now proof for the
is there is a Greek version of the Old
Testament and in the genesis of the
Septuagint and it says the earth was
without form and void it talks about the
earth being the abussos and so when it
says in Revelation Satan is cast to the
abussos and when the devil said to Satan
in the book of Job where did you come
from he said I came from the earth and
Jesus said I saw Satan cast down to the
earth and you read in Revelation 12
Satan was cast down to the earth so
where Satan is bound during that 1000
years on the earth the reason he's bound
in a special way is the Sun goes dark at
Christ's coming
so he's in darkness the Saints are that
are alive were caught up to meet the
Lord in the air the Saints that are dead
are resurrected the dead in Christ rise
at Christ's coming so if all the good
have left and gone with Christ he says I
go to prepare a place for you we receive
you unto myself that where I am he may
be he takes us up during that rapture
says the wicked are destroyed by the
brightness of his coming in 2nd
thessalonians so if everyone down here
is dead novel good people have been
saved and taken out Satan is bound here
with nobody to tempt let me give you one
more verse about that I think you look
in in mark chapter oh as actually Luke
chapter aids also mark chapter 5 these
demons
when they were going to be cast out of
the man the demon said to Jesus do not
cast us out into the the deep or the
nothingness in the word there is abussos
the same word you find in revelation
20:4 bottomless pit why the King James
translators got creative and used
bottomless pit there's still a mystery
they always think of Carlsbad Caverns
respectful with that yeah um yeah okay
that makes sense I guess one thing
that's confusing to me is like um when
he's loose you know this is after a
thousand years he's read the tempest
right the nation's I don't know that
race
yeah actually ten thing if no one here I
don't know like at the Dada or Dada and
we're in heaven loose after 2,000 years
who is actually tense in order that he
just efforts
I guess I'm well
good question the at the end of the
1,000 years if you read in Revelation 20
it says the rest of the Dead lived not
again till the thousand years are
finished that's an exact quote from the
King James meaning at the end of the
thousand years the wicked are
resurrected the Bible says they cover
the earth like a cloud they're described
as Gog and Magog
those are the enemies of God's people in
the Old Testament so the wicked Gog and
Magog are symbols for the wicked in the
Old Testament and so Satan now has got
this vast army to tempt and manipulate
and he leads them to attack the New
Jerusalem is as they launch this attack
on the beloved city you can read about
this also Zechariah 14 and then fire
comes down from God out of heaven and
devoured them after that white throne
judgment so you would really enjoy the
lesson we've got on the subject of the
thousand years and it's called the
thousand years of peace cliff let us
send that to you all you've got to do is
call the number and the number cliff is
one eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven that's one eight
hundred eighty three five six seven four
seven it's a great lesson yep hey thank
you so much for your question cliff and
we do have a couple lines still open 804
6 3 7 2 97 with your Bible questions our
next caller is Rick Rick there we go
Rick is our next caller from North
Dakota I believe that is if I'm doing
that right Rick here on Bible answers
live hi pastor Doug my question is in
first John chapter 5 6 verse 6 and 7 all
right a relation I have is I'm going to
ask this and I don't know if I can see
the forest through the trees here this
is the one who was came by water and
blood Jesus Christ not with water only
but with the water and the blood it is
the spirit who testifies because the
Spirit is truth for there are three that
testify the spirit the water and the
blood and these three are in agreement
that's my question to you how is the
watering of blood testifying
all right well knowing John
keep in mind when he writes about Jesus
death in his gospel and he talks about
the spear piercing the side of Jesus
it's a few distinct streams came from
the side you know ostensibly by the
heart of Christ water and blood it's
John who says you reading the Gospel of
John he said unless you were born of the
water in the spirit you cannot enter the
kingdom of heaven um when the children
of Israel and this is now first
Corinthians chapter 10
Paul compares the children of Israel
being saved from Egypt they needed to be
born of the water meaning they went
through the Red Sea and they were
baptized and they were born of the
Spirit and the spirit and the blood are
similar it's talking about born of the
fire there's a pillar fire and they went
through the water Jesus is telling
Nicodemus you've got to be born of both
water baptism we choose it's our
decision to come to Christ spirit and
blood baptism God chooses through his
promise and through the anointing of the
Spirit and so Paul is re John is using
the when he talks about the water in the
spirit in the blood he's using some
metaphors and when he says they witness
on earth he's talking about the power of
the Spirit to transform lives the
washing of how their lives are changed
and the blood you've heard about the
power of the blood that gives new life
there the Last Supper Jesus gave them
grape juice he said this is my blood and
it's through the blood were cleansed and
so not sorry go ahead yeah I guess the
other question was that in chapter 6 it
says this hour verse 6 and says this is
the one who came by water and blood what
does that mean well Jesus came into the
world he was baptized both ways
went Christ when he began his ministry
he was baptized in water at the end of
his ministry he was baptized he went
through the blood you might say not
only did he sweat blood in the garden of
gethsemane but he shed his blood at the
end of those three and a half years was
he okay so he accepts yeah I hope that
helps a little and it is a difficult
verse so I don't want to act you know I
don't want to be trite with it it is a
deep john is one of the deepest
theological writers here and he loves
using these symbols of course he wrote
revelation full of symbols but yeah I
think that's I think that's a basic
explanation for that trying to think
what we might offer Rick that would help
a little bit with that question and you
know the study got on baptism that we
started beginning to prep our impurity
we'll send your free copy of that Rick
if you'd like the lesson power in purity
just call the resource line the resource
number Rick is one eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven you just
call that number and you can get asked
for purity and power no sanity thank you
our next call is Kelley Kelley is
calling from our land of Florida Kelley
welcome you're on the air Bible answers
live hi hi thanks for waiting turn and
question I have a really odd question I
hate to change your subject of your
Bible study I've been going through a
lot of different changes here in my life
and when I was a young boy I was taught
to to love God and I know a lot about
Jesus and you know he was he died for us
last few weeks I've been noticing that
I'm getting bombarded by evil and I
don't know how to handle this is there a
place in the Bible that I can go to and
protect myself maybe award this away I
mean this is to a point where everything
around me is turning into
I can feel Satan just crying they like
that I understand
come yes yes well let me tell you if you
look at some of the Psalms and I'll name
two or three for you King David who was
chosen by God so God had a big plan for
his life but before he became king
between the time he killed Goliath and
became King at 30 years of age he was
attacked on every side he was forsaken
by his friends he was his own King and
government had a price on his head he
had to hide in the hills and live in a
cave and had to retreat to the enemy he
I mean he had his family kidnapped I
mean David really went through some
terrible struggles and then yet he's the
one who writes the Lord as my shepherd I
shall not want in Psalm 23 he makes me
lie down in green pastures though I go
through the valley of the shadow of
death now you might be feeling like
you're going through that right now
Kelly yeah it's not kind of rough it's
not death itself but it's got the shadow
of Dance in other words it feels pretty
bad let me tell you another Psalm that
David wrote if you look in Psalm 91
here's what he says
he who abides in the secret place of the
Most High who he who dwells in the
secret place of the most high will abide
under the shadow of the Almighty I'll
say of the Lord he is my refuge and my
fortress my god in him all trust he will
deliver you from the snare of the Fowler
that someone who captures birds and from
the perilous pestilence he'll cover you
with his feathers and under his wings
you'll take refuge his truth and his
shield will be your buckler you read I
can't read all of Psalm 91 right now you
reading Psalm 91 and you'll find a few
others in there that give great comfort
and you read those and you claim the
promises in there and there's power in
the word that even as you're reading it
to Lord I believe that will you put a
hedge around me he gives his angels
charge over you to protect you and so
he'll put a hedge about you but you got
to ask him and I don't I think you'll
find some encouragement reading the
Psalms and Kelly just to let you know
there's a book that we have it's called
tips for resisting temptation and it's a
great little book that pastor Doug did
put together
if you just call our resource line its
1-800 eight three five six seven four
seven and ask for that little book tips
for resisting temptation I think you'll
be greatly encouraged absolutely and you
know I just want to have a quick prayer
for you Kelly before we move on to our
next caller
father in heaven I just get here in
Kelly's heart that he's crying out he's
just under a demonic attack right now
and and I just pray that you'll send
angels to surround and protect us and
your good angels and I also pray that
your spirit will be in his heart give
him peace and comfort right now that
you're on the throne and though he might
feel like you know a thousand had fallen
at his side and he's surrounded by evil
you will never leave him or forsaken
because that's your promise and we thank
you and pray this in Christ's name Amen
amen
I know there's a lot of other people out
there like Kelly that are kind of going
through some trials and turn a valley of
the shadow of death Lord will give us
strength our next caller is Joe in
Arkansas Joe here on the Iran line here
Bible answers live all right Baxter how
are you good good appreciate your call
and your question well earlier in the
program you had said that God had hard
to get Satan in the Angels via fallen
angels to repent
I was just wondering uh say that
anywhere in the Bible is that that was
the first time I heard that and I just
thought it was a fascinating little kid
no it does not say that that is
speculation on my part but is based on
scripture the Bible says that God is
long-suffering and the Bible says he's
not willing that any should perish and
you look at the mercy and the patients
that got exhibited with humans and then
the Bible says we are made lower than
the Angels and so it would surprise me
if the first day that Satan or Lucifer
was a good angel then he had it for his
first evil thought that at that point
God threw him out of heaven I'm just
using the character of God as my proof
that he probably was patient with them
before they reached a point of no return
hmm I'm a visitor center yeah so I'm
just looking at the character of God it
you know there's
there's several verses in the Bible that
say he's long-suffering his mercy
endures forever God is patient and so it
just would be so out of nature for him
to tell Satan and one third of the
Angels the first day they do anything
wrong so you're out of here in your loss
forever and you go ahead to like a fire
so I'm sure that they kind there was a
period of probation for them as there is
for Humanity because God is loving like
any parent I was just going to say God
is love so what does that really mean
how far does that go but I'm glad you
called me on that Joe I got to be
careful not to just make those
statements I'm just enjoying the program
thank you for driving economy thank you
appreciate your call
great our next caller is John from
Detroit Michigan John you're on the air
with Bible answers live yes sir I'm a
first-time CO thanks for having me thank
you for calling our pastor I was going
to talk about one thing it was about
having a sense of humor in the Bible and
where is that located because I know God
gives everything to us and you know
where's the sense of people come from
but something Preston I heard about
Kelly for Orlando's okay if I talk about
that for a minute well as long as you
can frame it in a question I can okay
with the you see if I can do this and I
still hope I get a chance to answer your
question about laughter because I'd like
to okay I still hope I get a chance to
answer your question about laughter oh
you do okay you know what because you
answer the phone into a question I can't
really come up with the question I think
is kind of an answer for Kelly but
because you want to do something I'll go
back to that well that's okay you know
and I'm hoping you'll keep Kelly in your
prayers we want to encourage you but you
you also ask a question I think a lot of
people wonder about and the Bible talks
about avoiding foolish jesting and some
have thought that means that Christians
shouldn't laugh there is a verse that
talks about Jesus as a man
and this is Isaiah 53 I think a man of
sorrows and acquainted with grief and
they say he was a man of sorrows that
must mean he never laughed I don't think
it's saying that I think God does tell
us the laughs you can read in Psalm 126
2 it says then our mouth was filled with
laughter and our tongue was singing and
the Lord has got done great things for
them and so when God was doing great
things for his people it says they were
filled with laughter so you know last
year my left in the wall laughter during
that story yeah that way yeah and so
there's the wrong kind of laughter until
Bible talks about the wicked that are
the last group of fool is vanity
Solomon says in Ecclesiastes 7 6 but you
can find humor in the Bible let me give
you a couple of ideas where you might
see some samples when Jesus said if
you've got a speck in your eye and you
say to your neighbor that's got a log in
there I when I first read that if a log
must be a special spiritual meaning for
something no it means log it means a
two-by-four and so here you picture a
person that's got a little piece of dust
in their eye and they say to their
brother oh look you got a piece of dust
in your eye and you've got a log in your
eye and you're trying to help them it's
there's irony there's humor there when
when Isaiah was mocking the prophets of
veil and he said well you better cry a
little louder maybe your God is sleeping
you need to wake them up and you can see
even a little sarcasm there so yeah I do
think that we get our emotions from God
and you know they might be corrupted by
evil but I think God sings says in
Zechariah is F&I or rather I think that
God laughs and that fact there's a psalm
that says God's last but it's not a good
not a good example I was just thinking
of where a merry heart does good like a
medicine there you go yeah you know
absolutely there's healing in that
laughter yeah and you know sometimes
this life is
no one's going to want our religion if
we're not happy you know what I mean
right
and so I exactly agree yes and when
Jesus rose from the dead you know what
he said to the two disciples on the road
to Emmaus Luke 24 he said why are you
talking with each other and you're so
sad
the gospel is good news Christians
should be happy and if we're happy
people are going to want to enjoy that
we have now of course we're not talking
about frivolous happiness or people
telling dirty jokes we're talking about
the pure happiness from the innocence
all right things appreciate that John
good question our next question is Jim
Jim in Yakima Washington you're on the
air Bible answers live thank you
longtime listener first-time caller but
two verses it met Matthew 24 40 and 41
should I read them sure okay then then
shall two be in the field the one shall
be taken and the other left two women
shall be grinding at the mill the one
shall be taken and the other left and I
always said I thought I really
understood that I know Tim LaHaye built
his old program on I think on those two
verses yeah I don't don't think I ever
read the verse before that I was talking
about in the days of Noah right and it
says and then and knew not until the
flood came and took them all away
well you're onto something there I think
that these are some verses that have
been terribly misunderstood by the
Christian world everyone just reads
these verses by themselves and they
think two women are in the field one is
raptured and one is left behind two men
sleeping their bed one is raptured one's
left behind and two men working in the
field women grinding at the mill so
forth I think that the ones are taken
away here you've got to be very careful
because it says the flood came and took
them all away
now in the Jewish mind when you are in
the promised land and you were planting
your fields and you were baking bread
and you're resting in your bed that was
good that was a sign of peace and
happiness when the enemy came they took
you away the children of Israel were
taken away to a
Syria the people of Judah were taken
away to Babylon that was a punishment
when they were taken away the flood came
and took them away and then the
disciples asked the Lord where are they
taken and Jesus said wherever the
Buzzard is where the vultures are that's
where the bodies I'm sorry wherever the
bodies that's what the vultures are the
ones taken away in judgment well I said
that's where the vultures are so the
idea this whole Left Behind scenario
that's used for this verse is I think a
very gross misapplication of the verse
very simply the three examples Jesus
gives women sleeping in a bed working in
the field Matthew I think only mentions
to Luke mentions the men sleeping in a
bed - they have symbols in the Bible
sleep is a symbol for death Jesus said
our friend Lazarus is asleep when Christ
comes there's two kinds of people asleep
the dead in Christ and the ones who are
not in Christ you've got a woman
represents a church the bread they're
working with is a Word of God you get
true and false they're two women in
Revelation one is saved one is lost you
got men working in the field Jesus tells
a parable that the sower is sowing the
field he's doing mission work the seed
is the word of God
he's got several parables on that theme
you got different kinds of mission work
out that you get the true in the false
and so Jesus I think it's just basically
saying there's two kinds of people one
is going to be judged
you've got the wheat in the tares one is
lost one is saved but you don't get a
secret rapture I believe that we're
going to be caught up to meet the Lord
near but I don't think it's a secret you
don't get a secret rapture from these
verses can I send you a free book on
that subject Jim oh sure I've got a book
that's called anything but secret you
just got to make a phone call they'll
take your address send it to you and Jim
that number is 1-800-889-3518
Carol from Sterling Heights Michigan is
our next caller Carol you're on the line
with Bible answers live Thank You
first-time caller
thank you I want to know if if Jeremiah
29:11 is taken out of context if we try
to apply it to our lives today is it
just spent for the people that he 72
which was for I know the plans I have
for you declares the Lord plans to give
you hope and a future to prosper you can
we say that applies to everyone out of
context or is it just for those people
that he was talking to in the Bible I
believe that versus for everyone when
God makes a promise to ancient Israel we
get to claim those promises because you
look at the next verse and God says you
will search for me and you'll find me
when you search for me with all your
heart that's not just Jews that's
everybody jesus said seek and you'll
find and so the verse before that is God
says I've got good plans for you well he
wants you to be in heaven Carol that's
not just the Jews right okay he says
I've gone to prepare a place for you so
the promises that God made to Israel
Paul said those promises belong to us if
we believe them by faith because Paul
says if you are Christ's then you are
Abraham's seed and so you get to claim
these promises as a child of Abraham see
what I'm saying yeah so yeah the Bible
says he is not a Jew which is one
outwardly but he is a Jew which is one
inwardly and the Gentiles are grafted
into the promises of Israel through
Christ that doesn't mean the Jews are
excluded anyone who believes is included
and so the promise that God made through
Jeremiah to Israel is it he had good
plans for you I want to bring you back I
want to price for you well God has good
plans for us if we follow him he
promises to bless us you'll also read
that at the beginning of Deuteronomy
chapter 28 it Carol thank you very much
for your question and you know pastor
Marshall I don't think we'd be able to
do anybody justice in the minute that
we've got left for the live calls now we
do still have some amazing facts to
share with you through the rest of this
program friends
and so don't change the dial just yet I
want to just appeal to you before we
sign off here what we do here during
this one hour during the week is just a
fragment of what amazing facts has
available 24 hours a day around the
world and we have a television program
AF TV you can watch anywhere you get the
internet all the time we've got a
kaleidoscope in our Bible library just
go to amazing fact orz lots of materials
videos YouTube us Facebook us a lot of
material to grow you in your face
god bless until next week we'll talk
again thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth film
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G are you wondering what
lies ahead in human history for what
piece of world events are harbingers of
the end are you ready for the coming
crisis landmarks of prophecy offers
clear answers to your most pressing
questions presented by pastor Doug
Batchelor landmarks of prophecy is a
contemporary video Bible study adventure
designed for today's audiences
presenting the landmark themes of the
Bible in a bright and compelling way
helping you understand the Bible better
and giving you knowledge to face the
future with conference landmarks of
prophecy contains over 30 hours of
exciting video presentations on six DVDs
plus bonus question and answer sessions
giving you keen insight into what lies
next in human history if you'd like
practical tools to help you thrive and
survive in the here and now get
landmarks of prophecy start your epic
Bible study adventure with landmarks of
prophecy today
by calling
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF act 0rg and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 website at amazing facts
Arg did you enjoy this program make sure
to tell your family and friends tune in
next time for more Bible answers live
honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions
[Music]